katrina sam good to see you
congratulations on season six you know
season five ended with this really
powerful image of um of claire embracing
uh
claire
embracing jamie and saying that she felt
safe
how did she move forward in season six
following
all the trauma that she experienced
hi um you know it's not easy for her i
think on the surface she's put on a
really brave face and she's trying to
carry on with daily life as normal but
internally
she's still
coping with with what happened and not
very well as it turns out and i think
for claire up to this point she's always
been able to compartmentalize things and
move on past things quite easily in in a
weird way but this has really
um
it's really shook her to her core and i
think we we see her unravel in a way
that we've never seen before
and she begins to lean on
um
some rather unhealthy uh
mechanisms i suppose to try and
self-medicate
um
but
you know i think what's lovely is that
the writers have sort of explored her
journey with this
but also how this affects
not only her but her relationship her
family and and the people around her
on top of everything you know life on
the ridge is about to change with the
revolution on the horizon
you know sam
how
how does everybody balance
sort of knowing what's coming
with not wanting to affect too much
change with regards to what's coming
yeah it's the the i guess eternal
question that jamie and claire face
especially with their knowledge of the
future and
they in the past have tried to to change
the future or to to affect it in some
way and they now realize that
that it's relentless and you won't be
able to change faith so so instead they
try to just be on the right side and
currently yeah they're they're aligned
to the crown and
uh and know that that is going to be the
losing side so they will have to switch
to the patriots at some point but um
it it of course it's it's outlander but
it's
you know it's it's a it's a real
struggle for jaime he's constantly
trying to
to to play the british or to to avoid
any responsibility um but then
ultimately he's forced into it so
yeah the the revolutionary war is coming
and there's not a lot they can do about
it yeah um guys with so much time away
from the show between seasons i want to
know uh from you katrina what was the
more joyful reunion your reunion with
sam here who's been by your side this
whole time
or your reunion with travis the horse
ah
that's an easy one
um
no you know
sounds like the furniture you know i
always know he's gonna be there
but travis was a surprise you know he
was my he was my homie in season one and
then he went off to
bigger and better and brighter things
and uh you know i didn't i didn't know
he was gonna come back and pay us a
visit so it was a very nice surprise
seeing him
fantastic and sam listen
if your furniture buddy i think a lot of
people would be very happy to have you
uh as furniture in their home i'm just
saying millions of people will be happy
to have you as friends
or a
comfy couch yeah
all the best to you both thank you so
much for the time
thank you so much carlos